- Learning a language is
kind of like a video game.
I mean kind of, not exactly the same,
but let me explain.
(tranquil piano music)
I'm not a big gamer.
I've played my fair share
of Super Smash Brothers,
but that was like when I was a teenager.
But lately, I'm getting back into it.
We got a Nintendo Switch.
I've been playing it with my boys.
Zelda, this cool game called Cardo
has to do with maps, good times.
Another thing I've been
doing during quarantine
is not traveling.
Last fall when I started realizing
that COVID wasn't going away,
I would not be traveling anytime soon.
I decided to get my travel buzz
by learning a new language, Italian.
The language that is spoken
in my favorite region on Earth
right up here.
Four months ago, I didn't
speak a word of Italian
and today, (speaking foreign language).
So I've been driving back from work
and speaking to myself in Italian.
I am feeling my head.
There's like a physical
buzzing that happens.
(speaking foreign language)
For the past three months,
I've been studying Italian in the morning
and playing video games
with my kids at night.
I recently started to realize
how some of the major lessons
from video games can be applied
to learning a new language
and to do so in a much more efficient way
than was taught to us in school.
By the end of this video, I
want to explain this concept
of video games and language learning
and I want to give you my best takeaways
on teaching yourself a new language.
So back to video games.
My favorite video games
are ones with maps.
You'd be surprised, he's a big map guy.
He loves maps, I know,
I'm like a walking cliche.
I just like maps.
So if learning a language is
sort of like a video game,
here's the map of the video game.
This is the learning language journey.
You start here knowing nothing
about your new language
and your goal is to beat the final boss,
this elusive idea of fluency.
In other words, when you start your Link
and you just woke up from 100 year nap
and you have three hearts
and no weapons and no stamina
and no skills and no powers
and you don't speak the language,
where you want to be is like this.
Having lots of skills and tools
to navigate a conversation
with precision and
skill and beat the game.
In other words, to become fluent.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
This is a moment, this is a
thing I need to distinguish,
a distinction we need to make.
What is fluency?
What does that even mean?
I'll turn the question
on you gamers out there.
What does it mean to beat a video game?
One person will tell you
that beating a video game
means just beating the main storyline,
beating the main boss,
Ganon, Bowser, whatever.
I can already feel some
of you shaking your heads
because there are lots of you
out there that say no, no, no,
beating a video game
means beating everything.
All of the challenges,
all of the little things
like beating the shrines and
getting all the Korok seeds
and all the other things
that have nothing to do
with the main storyline.
You have to beat them all or
you haven't beaten the game.
So here's where the connection
between language learning
and the video game concept comes together.
When you're learning a
language in language school
or most formal programs,
the map looks like this.
You start here knowing nothing
and the journey to beat
the game to become fluent
is a long windy path with lots of gates
and trials and gatekeepers.
There are soldiers who are standing guard,
making sure that you beat them
before you go on to the next step.
You can't progress along this path
until you've memorized how to conjugate
the present imperative tense
including the irregular forms.
So you study them, you study, study, study
just to make it pass
this first gatekeeper.
You don't even really know
what present imperative means
but you look at the book, you memorize it
and you do what you need to do to show up
and pass the test so that you can move on
to the next thing that
they're teaching you
in this school formal environment.
So then you move on and you
get to the next gatekeeper
in the trial, which is you can't move on
until you've memorized the
subjunctive conjugations.
And you're like what
does subjunctive mean?
And it's just like I don't know,
but you need to go memorize it.
Oh, and memorize this random list
of 20 words that we think are important.
It's the only way to fluency.
If you want to be fluent, you
have to get through this gate.
I'll memorize the subjunctive.
You keep going on your journey,
passing the gatekeepers,
memorizing the concepts
that are in the book
that the teacher is telling you
and the idea here is that if you beat
all of these gatekeepers and
you memorize all these rules,
you make it to the final level
and you beat the final boss
and then you are fluent.
The problem is this
isn't a fun video game.
It's actually a grueling process
of memorizing abstract ideas.
So people don't actually beat
the video game very often.
They usually give up around
here and they say F it
and they throw in the towel
and they feel like language
learning is just not for them.
Meanwhile, some of us beat the game.
Like I actually beat the game in college.
I got a minor in French, like a minor.
Like I studied French
through all of the levels
in college to get a minor.
I beat this game and I
finally beat the final boss
and got here to the end of the map
and I had all the conjugations,
the direct object pronouns,
the past conditional and
auxiliary verbs and all of it.
And then I go to Paris and
I go to order a baguette
and I realized that I literally don't know
how to order a baguette in Paris
even though I have a minor in French.
There is nothing more
disappointing than that, it's sad.
Luckily, there's a happy
ending to this video,
this story that I'm telling you,
but right now, it's just sad
to think about getting a minor
in French and then not actually
being able to speak it.
I need a little bit of a change of pace,
I'm gonna crack open a bottle of wine.
Which begins the next segment
which is thanking today's sponsor
who sent me a giant box
full of literal wine.
Look at this.
Whoops, check this out.
This box arrived at my door two days ago.
Inside of the box, there
are some really cool things.
So Bright Cellars who
sponsored today's video
sent me this box.
They had me take a quiz
before on things that I like,
the type of food and the
types of personality traits
I have like all this whole quiz.
And then they used the
information from that quiz
to send me this box of wine.
What I like about this is
because when I go to buy wine
at a store, I have no guidance,
like there's no guidance for me.
I'm not super well-versed in
all of the different variables
that make good wine.
I'd like to be, but
it's big and complicated
and for someone to automate
that and to present it
in a way that's fun
and like sort of empowering
with information,
that's actually my favorite
part about the whole thing
is they will send me these
cards for each bottle of wine
that has a little infographic on it.
I like infographics, that's like my thing.
There's maps and there is origins
and there's a story about
like where this came from.
There's flavor notes if you're
into the flavor notes game.
For me, ritualistic things
like cheese and wine
and all of it is way more enjoyable
if there's a story associated with it.
Bright Cellars is giving 50% off,
which is half off for
anyone who clicked the link
in my description for
your first six bottles.
So you could sign up for this sweet thing,
get six bottles for 50% off
and it's a really good deal.
And again, the convenience,
the information,
the experience of this is really cool.
I'm excited, I'm excited to explore this
and have some knowledge and
story associated with it.
So thank you Bright Cellars
for sponsoring this video.
Let's get back to the story
of learning Italian
through a video game map.
I beat the game.
I got here and realized
that this version of fluency
was one where I had a deep
understanding of French grammar.
I even had an understanding
of its history,
I could read literature in French,
I could write properly,
I knew where all the accents went,
I even had a decent pronunciation
but I couldn't speak the damn language.
When I traveled to France,
wasn't that the whole point?
For all you Zelda people out here,
let's just say I had
gathered all the Korok seeds
and beat all the shrines
but still hadn't beat
a single divine beast.
The thing that actually mattered to me,
the thing I wanted to do,
what if I decided that this
isn't where I wanted to go at all?
This version of fluency wasn't important.
This isn't the game I want to play.
What if we decided to
take a different approach,
a different path, a much simpler goal.
And what if that goal were as simple
as I want to be able to
travel to a foreign country
and be able to speak to the locals
and have them understand me
and be understood when they speak to me.
Is that revolutionary like
no mastery of grammar,
no perfect pronunciation,
no ability to read and
write with any elegance,
no literature or cultural
history of the language,
just the ability to use
words to communicate
and then to understand the response.
Nothing else, no (squeaky
toy sound) Korok seeds.
I can already hear the comments,
but you're learning a language.
You have to know the grammar
or you won't be fluent.
Or in other words,
if you don't gather all the Korok seeds,
you didn't beat the game.
Listen, if my definition
isn't fluency for you,
I don't want your
fluency, I don't need it.
I just want to be able to go on a trip
and speak to the locals
and ask for directions
and have a conversation with
a taxi driver and order food.
That is all I want.
I'm being a little snarky here
because the language learning
community on the internet
has some very strong
opinions and expectations
about what real language
learning looks like.
You may see them in
the comments telling me
that my Italian actually isn't valid
because I don't understand
the past conditional tense.
Not sure how to respond to that,
but I reject your objection.
So a few months ago, I
set out to test this out
to see what this destination looks like.
Not this, but this.
I learned a lot and ended up
making an entire course about it
with my friend Nathaniel Drew,
but I want to summarize
the major things I learned
and share them with you.
(speaking foreign language)
Before I dive in and give you
exactly the things I learned
in this process, let
me do a few disclaimers
that might be helpful to some of you
who actually want to take away
some value from this video.
Number one is that this is my experience.
It's my experience,
it applies to me and my unique situation.
It worked well and it may work for you
and it may not work for you,
but don't see this as like
a plug and chug formula,
that is not what this is.
This is my perspective and my experience.
Number two, I want it to be clear
that I spoke literally zero Italian
in like October of last year.
I am fluent in Spanish,
which is a romance language,
which is like a cousin to
Italian and I did study French
in college as I've mentioned 57 times.
So I had some advantage
but the reality is I knew zero Italian.
I could say things like
ciao and like that was it.
(speaking foreign language)
That's what matters,
that's what I care about.
I rejected this and I
think there's a better way.
That doesn't mean it's easy,
it means that it's just more direct.
There are still trials,
they're just the most
efficient trials you need
and here they are.
Number one, not all
words are created equal.
The first thing I did was to
assess what are the most common
and useful 1,000 words in a language
and solely focus on those,
completely blocking out all others.
This isn't a new concept.
Scholarly research shows
that this is very useful
and history does too.
I last year was reading a lot
about American imperialism
for obvious reasons
and I stumbled upon this wild story.
After World War II, the British
and Americans who had just won the war
wanted to spread the English language
throughout the whole world.
So they adopted a stripped down version
that they called basic.
They were carefully selected words.
There were the most frequently used
and most useful 850 words in the language.
By the way, English has
like over 150,000 words.
And this language created
by a linguist of English
was only 850 words
and they use this to go promulgate
English around the world.
They're like anyone in the world
can learn English very quickly
if they just have to
learn these 850 words.
The inventor of the
language once said quote
it takes 400 words of
basic to run a battleship.
And with 850 words,
you can run the planet.
He literally said that like
this is an extreme version
of what I'm talking about here.
Some words are more important than others.
And if you just memorize those words,
those words that you
actually are gonna use,
then you can like supercharge
your language learning process.
Now this is where my friend Nathaniel Drew
comes into the story.
Nathaniel is a guy who
loves languages like I do
and he also believes in
this more direct path.
So he's challenged
himself to learn as much
of a new language as quickly
as he possibly can on his own.
By the way, much to the
chagrin of language learning
internet communities who love to say
that people are learning
languages the wrong way
because it doesn't fit their model.
In doing so, Nathaniel
realized the same thing
that British and American
governments realized
in like the 40's
that if you just prioritize
the most vital words,
the ones that you actually use,
you can rapidly acquire a language
if you block out all of
the words and only focus
on the most important.
Nathaniel had made a list
of what he deemed to be some
of the most important words
for his life and for just
everyday communication.
He gave me that list and I added to it.
I did a bunch of research on the data
of most frequently used words
and I put it together
into a list of 1,000 words
that I think are the startup kit,
the most important words
you need to memorize.
The ingredients, the
building blocks of language.
This is the first step.
Before you do anything else,
memorize the most important
words of a language.
How do you memorize all these words?
I'm not gonna go into it right now.
I have this box that I
use that has all my words
and in the course that we made,
I go into exactly how this thing works.
It's based on all the psychology
that forces these words
into your long-term memory.
The point is memorize the most vital
frequently used words first,
and your life will be a lot easier
in learning this language.
I saw this just recently,
like I went from knowing
zero words in Italian
to within the first week
knowing 200 words of Italian.
You can't speak super well
with just 200 words and no grammar,
but you can certainly
start to express yourself.
(speaking foreign language)
I kept memorizing and
soon I had like 500 words
and you won't believe what 500 words
can do for your ability to communicate.
This gets to the second trial
on our video game adventure,
which is start talking early.
Language isn't math.
In math, there are laws.
If you break those laws,
your equation won't work.
You literally get the wrong answer.
There are wrong answers
and right answers in math.
If my four year old son
says two plus two equals 22,
I will say no, son, that's wrong.
Two plus two equals four.
But if my son says
yesterday, I eated a apple.
I wouldn't say no son,
yesterday you ate an apple.
Get it right next time.
No, I wouldn't say that.
The kid said words, I understood them
and it worked, that's
language, it isn't math.
It's an expressive part
of our human experience
that is very intuitive and
very flexible and messy
like human culture and relationships.
It is not math.
When we approach language like this,
we make language feel like math.
Like if we don't get the
conjugations correct,
it'll be like we're saying
two plus two equals 22
and you'll be totally wrong
and no one will understand you.
And all that does is make
you nervous and averse
to actually speaking in real time.
But watch this.
I'm about to show you me speaking Italian
a month and a half, six
weeks after studying it,
going from zero words to a few 100 words
and trying to speak it.
Speaking with a native in Italy over Skype
and spoiler alert for
those Italian speakers,
my grammar is horrible.
(speaking foreign language)
But guess what, she understood me.
I was communicating in a
different language with somebody.
It's not pretty,
it's not linguistically
correct, but it's communication.
What I'm proposing is that
this is the alternative path,
this is the goal, not getting
the mathematical equations
of grammar and syntax correct.
As you memorize loads of words,
the next most important step
is to get yourself speaking
as soon as possible.
You'll have to do this eventually
if you want to speak the language
and it's awkward and painful.
And so you should start
early right away on week one
of learning the language
and you should get on
one of these services
and start communicating
with a native speaker.
And now I'm about to say
something that actually pains me
which is after two months of this,
just memorizing tons of words
and having weekly Skype
conversations with a native Italian,
I was speaking better Italian
more fluently than I was French.
I eclipsed my French capabilities
from a verbal standpoint,
not from a grammar standpoint,
but from a verbal expressive standpoint
after two months, compared
to four years of work.
I'm not saying it was
fluent after two months,
I'm just saying that my
experience after two months
was stronger than my four
years of college French.
That's like actually
sad for me in some ways
because there's so much
time of me learning French
and there's a better way.
In the course that I mentioned,
we go into a deep dive on
all the types of activities
that I do in one of these sessions
with a native speaker
that helps make it useful,
but I'm not gonna go into that right now.
Gate number three, you
got to make this fun.
Another major thing missing
from this model is fun.
Positive association is how it's called
in behavioral psychology.
The idea that your brain
wants to do something
if last time they did
it, it was sort of fun.
Language learning is hard,
it requires many months and years.
How do you keep it up?
You make it interesting and fun.
Grammar drills and
memorization are not fun
so you have to find ways to
make it a positive experience.
For me, that is reading
an Italian cookbook
that has Italian language
that I can translate
and think about Italian cuisine,
which is something I love.
I also started listening
to Harry Potter in Italian
which I didn't understand
a single word at first
but then I got the Kindle version
and I sort of followed along digitally
and translated some words
while I was listening
and now I can like
understand probably 80 to 90%
of Harry Potter cause I love Harry Potter.
Don't love JK Rowling
though, love Harry Potter.
So make it fun.
The last and final gate in
this more direct journey
to be able to speak a language is the one
that people who have
learned other languages
have been waiting for me to say
and they're angrily being like dude,
you got to mention this and
I'm gonna say it, which is yes.
Eventually, you have to learn the rules.
You have to learn grammar.
You have to learn pronunciation
and you have to refine it
through drills and
through a lot of practice.
Intentionally, I'm putting this last
because I think you should too.
The previous concepts
are way more important.
Get your first 500 or
1,000 words memorized
in your long-term memory.
Start speaking every week
with a native speaker,
make the journey fun, and then
start to think about grammar
and start to think about all
of the rules and the irregulars
and the syntax and the
direct object pronouns
and the past participles.
You can do that after
maybe two, three months
of like being in the trenches.
The best part about this
is that by that time,
you'll be in a place where you
can communicate basic ideas
so that when you do look at the grammar,
it actually fits into the context
that you've intuitively
developed of expression.
It won't just be like in a vacuum
of memorizing arbitrary rules,
it'll actually apply to something.
And that makes it way more
interesting to actually memorize.
I didn't start really going into grammar
until just recently,
three months into the
process of learning Italian.
And it makes a lot more sense.
So that is what I've learned
about learning another language,
it's like a video game.
You don't need to gather
all the Korok seeds
to beat the game.
You don't, some people think you do.
I'm not gonna listen to those people.
For me, to beat the game,
you just need to be able
to talk and be understood.
This is my experience,
this is my version of it.
And again, in the course,
I go deeper into exactly
how this goes down.
The course that me and Nathaniel did
is like three and a half hours
of like nitty gritty techniques
and all of this stuff,
but the message is what
I've told you here,
which is that there's a
better way to learn languages
than the way we learned it in school.
I will be studying Italian for years,
but the beautiful thing is
next time I go to Italy,
which who knows when that's gonna be,
but at some point I'll go to
Italy, I'll show up to a cafe
and I'll be able to speak.
I'll be able to talk and be understood
and that's what matters to me.
So I hope that's what matters to you too.
Thanks for watching.
(speaking foreign language)